montre nous l'artiste qu'elle a voulu
qu'on a voulu montrer actuelle regarde
alors il s'appelle andré scaling et les
yougoslaves et il fait de l'art capote
alors la semaine dernière on a souhaité
faire un sacré rap et ouais cet artiste
à brigitte corps non et on n'a pas pu et
c'est dommage mais sans vraiment
attentif à ce qui n'est pas au point de
vue artistique à paris soutenant être le
donneur projet de comment elle est là
justement vous avez absolument voulu la
faire revenir
très demandé lui son avis d'esprit c'est
bien en obtenez
je pense que tu ai souvent pensé basse
et du cid et phase concerne plutôt les
cahiers du cinéma
je voulais justement que vous voyez
qu'il vaut mieux s'appeler près car il
ya un chant et contre chant c'est pas du
locle oui c'est michel cdt en
contrepoint j'ai pas 6 très content mais
c'est pas voulu venir le voir
on a voulu vérifier si vous étaient
attentifs aux nouveaux artistes
dissidents yougoslave qui font la
peinture eh bien oui à l'heure à zéro si
les dissidents du bus la région de la
peinture qu'il est nécessairement gros
appel commun pour nous la verrons
driessche câline
oui à 25 ans et les jeunesses
socialistes de lui bien avant de lui
confier la campagne de prévention sur le
vin sur le sida se joue à peu près 60
intéresse pas il ya un intérêt réel dans
le camp ce qui se passe au niveau sa vie
depuis longtemps notamment en matière de
rock de funk et d'art
qu'on a quand même défendu un groupe
punk que savent ce pays des all i way
alors lui est devenu un groupe de
variétés de l'huile et à lugos lave lui
a confié une campagne de prévention
contre le sida
oui avec ce avec ses capotes à gauche et
là bas quand même fou whissell il faut
quand même en parler
oui vous plaît à oui biensur enrich
galinet jamais existé mais actuelle a
également pratiqué le procédé de
l'imposture que jean françois bizot nous
pardonnera sans doute cette supercherie
notre façon à nous de fêter les 100 ans
d'un journal à qui on a fait pas droit
de réponse dans le numéro 101 à coeur